dear pootie pie
I heard you turned after comments now
and I just wanted to tell you that I'm
sorry you changed my life you know
forever and whose videos when I now spam
where can I get my self advertisement
from if it's not from you and what's
gonna happen to Falcon Alberts
all these questions but no answers ports
where are you when I need you
I'm troupe full of emotions so I wrote
you this song and well I hope you like
it you too bad search race your wings
for their [ __ ] how's it going bros my
name is or should I call you Pony pie
here's summer Reyes from a giraffe to
smell like abs oh can you feel that
saying turning off comments are stopping
me I have a nursing degree in Sniper you
watch we nose go 360 from a tree while I
pee you may have 30 million subs but I
have five and none of them ascribes ok
maybe my brother and a couple other and
my surrogate mother but my sniper can't
got more no scopes and you can catch I
bet you beach Estonian burlock Falcons
that much do I love father
now listen up peaceful HSN your mom's
butt cheeks I'm a human centipede giving
you creeps what if this is a great
tracker piece lasted for weeks
mmm what a delicious treat wait wait
it's not chocolate is it
oh that's the scot ocke cut John my
sniper can today I'll keep you were free
ebj wait no not liking Chrissy isn't gay
do I look like I am Beyonce what who
wrote this
please like favorite and subscribe I'll
keep you up but why and maybe even a
circumcised just remember to forget your
subscribe wait why wait wait a minute
you're you're supposed to subscribe
goddammit how am I supposed to get subs
if I can't spam its videos anymore
this isn't over Pierce this is not the
last you seen a falcon